ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Academy Award winner Jeremy Irons
the nominations for screenplays are
voted by the writers branch of the
Academy a nomination verifies every
writer's deeply felt opinion of himself
damn I'm good
the nomination for Best Screenplay
written directly for the screen are Gary
Ross the Dave Jeff McGuire for in the
line of fire got a nice wayna for
Philadelphia Jane Campion for the piano
Nora Ephron David s Warren Jett art for
Sleepless in Seattle
and the Oscar goes to Jane Campion for
the guy
well when I was a student which doesn't
feel like so very long ago
he's feel deeply cynical about award
nights like this but tonight I'm really
overwhelmed in fact I've been close to
tears a few times and I'm just very
pleased to be here and very proud to win
this award and I'd like to say very big
thank you to my actors Holly
Anna Harvey and Sam who aren't here but
were such gorgeous tender and vulnerable
men in the piano I'd like to say Michael
Nyman your music was just so
extraordinary for me it was the heart of
the film Jan thank you for being my
friend and producer a great big kiss to
you Colin my husband
and the special thank you to the mirror
marks brothers RV involved bringing this
film to America thank you very much
you